we talked about god of war maybe be
showing god a war for Alexei you were
saying hey I may be some sort of Norse
god of war game and it is and it's just
straight off called God of War I pray
dose his back as well training his son
to do something yeah his son who sucks
at hunting so it's a it's a it's a daddy
name yes yeah much like Gears of War
this is the new trend we're seeing yeah
Peter before we went live you were
saying look if they had to go back to
God award that the gameplay of those old
games it's a little bit trite you know
in 2016 they're gonna have to shake it
up this is what they did right I mean
it's it's maybe it's not maybe it's not
new but it's like very different anyway
it's a previous card i mean changing the
perspective by bringing the camera
that's close to kratos is a smart move
and honestly it was sort of the thing
that I was hoping because watching the
gameplay before from the top down thing
is just like man like we need to be in
this action you know not like during
just a cutscene battle but actually like
in the moment-to-moment gameplay and
sure enough here we are seeing that it's
super impressive and I'll be honest like
the sort of at the moment with him and
his son when the animal was dying I've
never seen anything like that and got
more game before like no and that
actually felt like inspiring emotion
from me
like I I'm super impressed by the whole
demo for the most part like big tonal
shift from the God of War you know
hoorah tearing things head off and
having like but it's you know like they
dive into that in a much deeper way you
know what I mean yes we'll have to see I
guess I've been in the sex scenes much
deeper they do much deeper and triangle
buttons and do we think you'll play as
the child do we think this is a prologue
to a game when you play as the kid you
do a little bit I mean they sort of show
you get to aim the bow and arrow so I
presume yeah that's a good indication
what you think Alexa I'm really excited
that there's no fixed camera right I
like that you can explore the world I
totally think I mean if you're training
the kid if they're rebooting this
they're gonna do a series presumably in
this God of War era maybe the next game
if there is another game is a kid like
maybe this is you preparing him to
become the new God of War well what do
we think about I guess the
what we're looking at here in terms of
you know era or culture or whatever
because it doesn't like like I don't
know thing about Norse mythology but it
doesn't immediately jump out of that to
me so when that guy popped out he said
something something something Valhalla
yeah okay all right so there you go but
is it I don't know when Kratos used his
like rage thing it's called Spartan rage
why so it's a it's not like some sort of
like weird reboot of the character I
mean it's the same in same iteration
yeah you think it's Kratos just like
years later he's just like you know what
raising a trace is messed up and I'm
gonna go to Norway Iceland maybe yeah
interesting stuff it's like a different
interpretation of the God of War right
like the Spartan rage out there and then
it's like you know it's all back and
like they didn't really reveal his name
either writing in the blanks here look
at that look at that I got angry is I
really like the beard yes the beard is a
big improvement I love that he just
starts punching it here even there like
here's the weapon strapped to his back
yeah and like just going straight for
the tendon I think well he wants his son
to get the the final kill right this was
pretty funny
I mean it's XP the kid fluffed it a
little bit he's gonna get that killed
that ratio and then nope oops hit my
dad's it's good thing he's great us or
maybe Kratos okay moving on I guess